people of the internet retroreckons who
are here and today we are taking a deep
dive look at the ravenclaw common room
and like the others we have reviewed so
far there are so many little details
here that fans are just going to
absolutely love let's not waste any more
time let's dive straight in and one
thing that is immediately prominent here
and one thing that i really love about
all the common rooms is the colors they
are instantly familiar i mean the very
first shot the blues and the bronze they
really stand out here and also the first
thing that stands out about this common
room is just how organized everything is
i mean everything is ridiculously
organized which is in pretty stark
contrast to the gryffindor common room
that we just reviewed also you guys may
notice i'm not doing as many transitions
in this video some people in the last
video said they didn't really like that
actually made them feel a little queasy
so we're gonna try and just keep it a
little more simple here so let me know
if you guys like this method better you
won't see as many scene changes but you
will see me kind of clicking around a
little more organic experience here so
in the slytherin common room we talked
about the dark stone in the gryffindor
common room we talked about the stone
mixed in with the dark wood here in the
ravenclaw common room everything is so
much lighter it's airy being in the
tower like they are right here and
considering the fact that the mascot is
an eagle i mean it just feels like the
sky almost and right here at the top of
the screen you can see there are some
stars on the ceiling there and then
whereas gryffindor just has rugs kind of
all over the place here we have
ravenclaw with just this one giant rug
here but it's nice and centered
everything's symmetrical and you have
some seating here and then really the
only kind of clutter in this room is all
of the stacked books right here so of
course you know the ravenclaws are going
to have books stacked up all right after
letting this same scene here play a
little bit further in we see a couple of
new things have entered we have the
eagle here on top and then how can we
ignore the giant statue here of rowena
ravenclaw again that was one thing that
i noticed that was very different about
the gryffindor common room is that their
founder was not featured anywhere that i
could find in that scene or scenes
rather let's talk about the railing as
well i love this design here it almost
feels like the outside of like a palace
garden or something then over here on
the left side we have this pedestal with
the vase on top of it i guess and you
can just tell that this was so well
thought out i mean everything has its
place here we saw a harp very similar to
this in the slytherin common room so it
seems like the ravenclaws have a harp
here as well a little teacup over here i
mean of course the ravenclaws are going
to just sip their tea as they study it
really does just fit perfectly for this
house and now from this view here we
have an even better view of the ceiling
so you can see those stars then we'll
let it move forward to the next scene
and immediately we see another house
banner here on the left side still
trying to figure out why gryffindor had
so many of the hogwarts house banners
whereas the other houses seem to be
focusing primarily just on their own
house there was that one spot in
slytherin with what looks like a
ravenclaw crest and i'm still not really
sure why it was there we do have a
portrait over here on the right side as
well ravenclaw has a few portraits but
not nearly as many as we saw from
gryffindor they do have a little bust
statue right here and then over here on
the left side a telescope which i mean
in the tower to study the stars to look
out at the night sky it makes a lot of
sense now here on the right we see a
chest that looks very similar to the
chest that we talked about in the
gryffindor common room clearly this is
going to be interactable in-game for
some kind of storage we just don't
really know what exactly yet is it going
to be ingredients like potion
ingredients is it going to be things
related to class is it going to be
something related to the lost items is
it gonna be our clothing is it gonna be
all items and i guess where i'm still
confused is why we wouldn't be able to
take certain items out into the field
with us we all know hermione had that
incredible epic bag in harry potter and
the deathly hallows which seemingly had
no bottom to it she could store all
kinds of things in there so that would
actually be a very nice mechanic for a
video game to have so it's interesting
that they don't seem to be going with
that or maybe they do i don't know but
it's like what would be the reason then
for having to come back to your common
room to retrieve some sort of supplies i
guess it could be clothing that's
another possibility as well and i'd love
to hear what you guys think what are we
going to store in these little chests
right here that are in multiple common
rooms let me know in the comments below
of course more books here for the
ravenclaws they gotta have lots and lots
of books a grandfather clock that looks
very similar to the one that we saw in
gryffindor and then on the left side
this is a big one right here the flu
flame and a flu flame that is lit now
these have been confirmed as fast travel
points for the game we have seen them
throughout the last few trailers and it
certainly makes a lot of sense to have
them i'm a little surprised that they
put them inside the common room though
because there is such a big emphasis in
the books and i mean it seems like
they're putting a big emphasis on the
entrances as well you know there's only
a specific way that you can get in i
wonder if they'll have some sort of
in-game explanation or some in-game
mechanism that would prevent players
from traveling into this common room i
mean obviously from a gameplay
perspective all you have to do is if
you're playing another house and you're
never able to enter the ravenclaw common
room then you won't even have that flu
flame unlocked so it wouldn't make sense
for you to have it unlocked there'd be
no way for you to travel there but as
you're gonna see here in a second when
we take a look at the entrance there are
some ravenclaws sitting outside the
entrance where it looks like they're
struggling to think of the riddle which
fans of the series of course know to get
into the ravenclaw common room you have
to answer a riddle so gryffindor and
slytherin are both passwords hufflepuffs
involves tapping the brick to the tune
of helga hufflepuff but the ravenclaw
one most challenging by far but if they
could just travel in by flu flame then
it's like why are they sitting out there
i don't know i get it it's one of those
things that's probably necessary to have
for a game you might need a quick way to
get immediately back into the common
room but i still think it might have
been better if they had just placed it
somewhere right outside the common room
now we do know that the flu flames in
the common rooms is something that is
supported by cannon in fact it was a
really big deal in harry potter and the
order of the phoenix because remember
they had to get into umbrage's office to
use the flu network that was the one
spot that she hadn't shut down all the
other ones were shut down and that of
course is how harry had been
communicating with sirius through the
flue powder so it was kind of like a way
where you don't travel all the way
through but remember sirius's head
appeared in the fireplace there so
having the flu flames in the common room
is something that's part of canon it'll
kind of be interesting to see how they
implement it here we're going to zoom in
here a little bit closer as the scene
moves on and over here on the left we
have more books on the bookshelf a
couple of magical artifacts maybe right
here
i love this right here a little spot for
an umbrella and then this just beautiful
archway right here i mean everything
about the ravenclaw common room is
absolutely beautiful it's very proper
though for me personally i already told
you guys i'm at home in gryffindor that
is where i would want to hang out i
would feel that i could be really
relaxed there here i feel like i would
need to be really sort of minding my
manners at all times you know like
you're at a really fine restaurant you
don't want to be too loud that is the
vibe that i get from here which i guess
for ravenclaws you guys are probably
happy about that you know it would be
very quiet if you're trying to study
here because you know people are going
to always be trying to study in the
ravenclaw common room makes perfect
sense and let's talk about the little
floor here i love the transition from
the stone into the hardwood i mean this
is just gorgeous right here this little
area right here and then we get another
close look over here on the left side at
the ignatia wildsmith because she is the
inventor of flu powder so that is the
statue or the bust i guess that we see
right here along with the green flue
flame we'll shift it forward just a
little bit more here and man i love this
medallion right here just featuring the
eagle of ravenclaw yes guys the mascot
of ravenclaw is an eagle not a raven i
still have some people who will
occasionally pop in the comments and say
it's a raven what are you talking about
like guys no actually
it's not it's an eagle then you have the
two knights here over on the right side
i think would be hilarious if they are
guarding the girl's dormitory and so if
you try to go that way as a boy you're
just gonna get blocked remember on the
gryffindor side if the boys tried to go
up on the girls side it would just turn
into a slope so the stairs would
immediately turn into a slide so they
would have no way of making it up so my
guess is that these right here are
leading into the boys and girls
dormitories and then here this next room
would just be an incredible place to
study you have the fire right in the
middle all this light i just love the
windows and how much light is pouring
into this room here the ceiling is
absolutely gorgeous and then i wish we
could get a closer look at this tapestry
directly behind this because i mean it
looks like wings right here on the left
and right side the white here on the
left and then the white over here on the
right i mean this is clearly wings is it
just a giant eagle we see another
telescope over here on the left side as
well as another one of these which they
actually interact with going through the
gryffindor common room and i gotta say
these large wing back chairs they're
similar to the gryffindor ones colors
are a little bit different and i don't
think they look quite as cushy quite as
comfortable moving forward a little bit
more here another bus statue that we can
make out now over on the right side and
then right here this is great i think
this looks to be someone who has been
working on their art over here looks
like a painting they've been working on
the books just piled up everywhere
another desk here with lots of books on
it another new scene here and guess what
more books you've got the really large
bookshelf here an hourglass right here
which would make sense you know if
they're working on a project or working
on potions and there are certain things
that they need to time having that
hourglass nearby would be very handy a
little cauldron here on the left side
and over on the right some sort of lock
box this kind of looks similar to the
one that we saw in slytherin maybe not
exactly the same and then here in the
middle of the shot another telescope i
really do want to know if these
telescopes are going to be items we can
interact with i mean imagine if you can
use these to like look out on the
hogwarts grounds or to look out at the
night sky i mean who knows maybe
astronomy is actually going to be a
class in this game and we'll need to
utilize the telescopes for the class but
we have seen them now here in the
ravenclaw common room and then i'm
pretty sure we saw something that looked
almost exactly like this in the
slytherin common room but it was
positioned where you could look out into
the depths of the black lake then just
to the left of this desk here we have
this trash can where you can see that
somebody has just been like constantly
trying to get something written and then
just tossing it into the bin here also
have some ink bottles and quills over
here on the left again this really does
just look like it would be an amazing
place to go and study as you've got all
that light pouring in there you can look
outside get a view of the night sky get
a view of the hogwarts grounds while
you're studying and then that scene
actually moves a little bit forward so
we can see more of this artwork here it
looks like someone has actually been
working on a painting of the hogwarts
grounds here and then a note right here
tucked in behind this picture aren't you
just dying to know what this note says
probably just some boring homework but
still i am so curious boring homework in
the wizarding world would be pretty
interesting to we muggles right and now
we move to one of my favorite parts the
entrance for ravenclaw so even outside
of the ravenclaw common room you see
they have books here a couple of
bookshelves kind of tucked away in these
cabinets here we also have to comment on
the ravenclaw robes here because they
are incredible as well looking so nice
these house robes they did a phenomenal
job but i'm going to freeze it right
here because i want you to look over
here on the left side we can see one
student here in this view there are
actually two sitting on the bench right
here and so this is what i was talking
about with the flu flame earlier so i
think what they're going for right here
is that these two students can't get in
they're ravenclaws but they can't make
it into the common room because they
can't solve the riddle so part of me is
like why don't they just take the flu
flame i mean is this their first time
actually going into the ravenclaw common
room maybe there's some sort of magic
that works where you have to solve the
riddle at least once a day so you can
use the flu flame i don't know you could
explain just about anything with the
magic right because as a little fun
detail for fans i love that they did
this it's just i keep thinking about
that flu flame and it's throwing me off
but the fact that they have students i
mean this was a thing from the book
you have students outside the common
room struggling because they can't solve
the riddle and then as the character
goes up i'm gonna let this one play
because i think this animation i don't
think it's getting enough love guys i
think that is a glorious animation it
just looks so good everybody's talking
about the slytherin one and for good
reason because it's amazing but i don't
think this ravenclaw common room
entrance is getting enough love because
that animation is so slick it just looks
so good as the eagle kind of folds its
wings in opens the door and then as soon
as it opens you get another eagle
waiting there a large stone eagle kind
of like it's saying well done you know
well done for solving the riddle well
done for being accepted into ravenclaw
then we have the astrology patterns here
on the ceiling and the next shot is the
very first scene we had but from a
different perspective we're gonna walk
right by the ravenclaw statue here on
the right it looks as if she is holding
a wand here in the left hand and then a
book in her right hand and we've also
seen this room before but not quite from
this angle so you have the really large
globe over here on the right side the
teacups the teapots there on the table
here we also get a much better view of
the rug and the astrology patterns that
you can see on that as well and then
just before they change scenes here we
do get a look at another portrait here
on the left side i believe we already
saw this one on the right here so they
do have a couple of portraits throughout
the ravenclaw common room again just not
nearly as many as we see in the
gryffindor common room all right then in
the transition to the next scene we get
another bulletin board here on the right
also a bulletin board with the chubbly
cannons poster we already talked all
about that chudley cannons poster in our
gryffindor common room video breakdown
so if you missed that you can check it
out there a long story short some fans
think that this could mean the game is
going to last longer than one school
year i'm still not convinced i don't
think that's exactly what it's saying
but seeing yet another notice board like
this does give me hope that we will have
that old feature from the original harry
potter games where you can retrieve lost
items for fellow students alright let's
talk about this next room here because
wow the lighting man the lighting and
really in this entire common room but
especially in this spot right here is
amazing again we have that same metal
railing that we've seen earlier then we
have this spiral staircase oh i cannot
wait to go up that spiral staircase guys
and look out over hogwarts i mean we
know the ravenclaw tower is one of the
highest points in hogwarts astronomy
tower is going to be the tallest but
then you also have gryffindor tower
ravenclaw tower they're pretty high up
there as well so this is going to make
for just an incredible view i mean we
got to be able to go up there right they
wouldn't have put these stairs in if we
can't go up there so please photo mode
it's gotta be in the game because we are
going to get some truly amazing shots i
really can't wait people are so creative
with the photo modes online it's gonna
be incredible to see what people come up
with then the camera moves forward a
little bit more and they give us a look
upward at that dome shape the window
shining through and then you get an even
better look at these metal eagles going
all the way around right here also i am
trying to figure out what this thing is
over here on the left i mean is this
kind of like a birdhouse or something
what
exactly is this and i gotta say this is
the first spot where we actually see
some overlapping rugs here like the
gryffindor common room everything else
that has been so nice and neat here
they're like okay we gotta have a few
extra rugs here so there is some overlap
here and over here on the left side as
well in this common room they show off
yet another one of those interactions
again using the same item this sort of
sphere
whoa this is crazy i just noticed this
as i was letting this play through in
slow motion the character actually whips
out their wand it looks like the wand is
like tucked up in their shirt
watch this because right here they don't
have a wand
and then all of a sudden if i move it
forward look now they got a wand and
they kind of like
lightly sort of toss their wand in the
direction of the spherical object over
here getting it to spin
so i don't remember if they had a wand
in the gryffindor common room or not
when they spun that i'm gonna have to go
back and look at that i thought it was
just a hand yeah let's watch it play in
slow motion here and you'll see the
character right there they pull out the
wand give it a little shake and the
object spins i think we should call all
of these little individual desk areas
and like individual bookshelf areas like
call these study nooks here some nice
little study nooks for the ravenclaws
here throughout the common room couple
of more portraits over here on the right
and you guessed it more books then we're
back in this room here and they give us
another tease such a tease right here of
being able to see the bottom of the
eagle but i want to see this whole thing
because man it is going to look
incredible when we can see that entire
eagle on that back tapestry but how
about the ceiling right here just
absolutely gorgeous if you missed my
breakdown of gryffindor i'm gonna put
that video on the left side of your
screen now and hufflepuff will be up
next once that one's done it'll be on
the right side of your screen as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon